yesterday we asked the president about
this along with many other issues - I
were running fewer commercials and
airing our extended interview with the
president here's part one of that
conversation
mr. president think you're doing this
thank you the reaction to your press
conference in Washington was swift and
intense former CIA director John Brennan
described it as treasonous and a
potentially impeachable offense why the
push toward conflict with Russia in
Washington on both sides well I think
Brennan is a very bad guy and if you
look at it a lot of things happened
under his watch I think he's a very bad
person I also think that when you watch
Peter Strock and Lisa page when you
watch all of the things that have
happened in Qom happened call me take a
look at that and McCabe who's got some
pretty big problems I assume you look at
the deception the lies what's gone on in
the last fairly long period of time
before I won I mean long before I won
during the campaign I guess probably
during the Republican you know when I
was fighting against 17 other
Republicans so this has been going on
for a long time but these are people
that in my opinion are truly they're bad
people and they're being exposed for
what they are and it's a shame that it
has to happen but it's really hurt our
country their view is that the United
States is forever in conflict with
Russia which is our chief global
adversary and anyone who doesn't believe
that is betraying the United States
without taking up whether that's sure
not why do you think there is this
bipartisan consensus on that in
Washington what sort of incredible
because you've look at the World War one
and World War two that was Germany and
in World War two Russia lost 50 million
people and helped us win the war and I
was saying to myself the other day I
said you know Russia really helped us
I'm not pro Russia Pro anybody I just
want to have this country be safe
I don't want nuclear weapons even people
thinking about it you know Russia and
the United States control 90% of the
nuclear weapons in the world and getting
along with Russia and not only for that
reason that's a good thing not a bad
thing are they are chief adversary would
you say well they're strong military
but their economy is what smaller as you
know than China and I don't want to even
use the word adversary we could all work
together we can do great everybody can
do well and we can live in peace but I
think it's very very important you know
and I've watched your show a lot and I
see how you're talking about the MEK
really the Magnificent size of China you
look at the size at what they've done in
a fairly short period of time that's
because of a lot of bad leadership on
behalf of the United States we allowed
that to happen we allowed them to make
hundreds of billions of dollars and
right now as you see and you probably
have noticed that things are happening
we have to bring it more into line we
have to level the playing field between
the United States and China and we've
increased our net worth we've increased
our worth by more than seven trillion
dollars since the election and we're
about twice the size of China our
economy but China still is a massive
economy they have the second biggest by
far so NATO NATO was created chiefly to
prevent the Russians from invading
Western Europe I think you don't believe
it's Western Europe's at risk of being
invaded by Russia right now so what is
the purpose of NATO right now well that
was the purpose and right it's okay it's
fine but they have to pay and they
weren't paying and other presidents went
and they'd make a speech and then they'd
leave and nothing would happen and you
know the fact that they didn't pay is
not you know new it's not a new fact
this is something that people have known
for a long time other countries were
delinquent you know the real estate
business we use the word delinquent they
didn't pay they didn't pay for passed so
I went there three four days ago and I
said folks you got to pay because we're
not gonna pay from 70 to 90 and I think
ninety is really the right you know
depending on the way you define at
ninety percent we're not going to pay 90
percent of the cost to defend Europe and
on top of that the European Union kills
us on trade we lost 151 billion dollars
last year on trade they don't take our
product they don't take our farmers
beautiful goods they don't take our cars
and if they do
the rate of taxes many times what we
would charge them we only charge them
two and a half percent their tax their
tariff is is very substantially higher I
mean in the case of China we charge two
and a half percent when they send a car
and when we send a car into China that
you are just twenty five percent how is
that fair trade you know people say oh
we want to keep we don't want tariffs
but how is that fair when one country
gets twenty five percent in another
country gets two and a half percent and
by the way the one getting twenty five
doesn't even want the cars they want
them to build those factories they want
those factories built in China they want
those factories built in Europe so now
we're doing things that have never been
done before in this country and you see
what's going on it's been variable to
membership in NATO obligates the members
to defend any other member that's
attacked so let's say Montenegro during
last year's attack why should my son go
to Montenegro to defend it from attack
why is that and what you're saying I've
asked the same question
you know Montenegro is a tiny country
with very strong people Albania by the
way they're very strong people they have
very aggressive people they may get
aggressive and congratulations you're in
World War 3 now I understand that but
that's the way it was set up don't
forget I just got here a little more
than a year and a half ago right but I
took over the conversation three or four
days ago and I said you have to pay you
have to pay and the Secretary General
said that because of President Trump
last year we had an additional forty
four billion with the beef billion
dollars raised for NATO and this year
it's going to be much more than that and
the countries all agreed it was very
unfair they weren't paying so we're not
only are we paying for most of it but
they weren't even paying and we're
protecting them add that to your little
equation on Montenegro as you traveled
around Europe and looked at Europe over
the years can you think of a place that
has been improved by mass emigration of
the movements of large numbers of
refugees a year ago they would have been
totally insulted now maybe there could
have been a couple out of all of those
countries I said the immigration
policies in Europe are a disaster you're
destroying Europe you're destroying the
culture of Europe the crime is up in
those areas and you better do something
I tell them that I said look it's not me
it's not anything you just look at the
numbers and numbers speak but the
culture is changing rapidly and the
crime rate is changing more than rapidly
you better do something I told them that
what are the lessons for us watching
that well we have to be very strong on
the border now we're much stronger than
we ever were and the border and our
numbers are much lower but still we're
getting the wall we're gonna have we're
putting in for about five billion
dollars we've already started the wall
1.6 billion and started in San Diego
California it's almost completed in that
area and by the way that people were
really asking for it you know it's
interesting they probably go down as
though we don't want the wall but when
it came to their backyard they wanted
that wall and they wanted it up fast but
we've started the wall we are going to
continue with the wall that's so
necessary but we have to have strong
immigration policies our laws are so bad
Tucker somebody comes in and they step
on our land and now we end up with a
court case that takes seven years but
the people never show up to court it's
so bad and we have to do something about
it like if they come into our land we
have to say I'm sorry you have to leave
not I'm sorry please come to court we're
gonna put you in court you'll come back
in three years for your travel and then
they never show up that's what well
that's what's happening now it's crazy
why do you think so many political and
cultural leaders in the United States
disagree with you and are making the
case that borders are themselves immoral
it's incredible I mean the Democrats are
for open borders which means crime it's
not a question of like you know what do
you think it means open borders means
crime and you look at ms-13 is pouring
in and we stop them better than anybody
else could but when they get through and
then we send ice because ice is tougher
than they are and now I understand
there's a big move to try and get rid of
ice but ms-13 these are tough
vicious people they don't like guns they
like using knives better because it's
more painful these are vicious people
and you you know the story you cover it
plenty
and ice goes in and they get him out
they get him out they put him in jail or
they throw him out of the country and
they don't even think about it and now
there's a move on to get rid of ice
because ice is stuff if you don't have
tough people doing that job you're gonna
have crime like you've never seen it so
it is incredible the Democrats want open
borders which is basically saying we
want open borders we want crime why do
you think they want that maybe it's a
political philosophy that they grew up
with maybe they learned it at school
maybe they're fools I don't know